en la capital libanesa beirut frente al
tribunal de Justicia familiares de las
víctimas de la explosión del puerto en
2020 manifiestan su indignación todos
apoyan al juez tarak vitar el magistrado
encargado de investigar la explosión del
4 de agosto de 2020 es procesado por
rebelión contra la justicia y usurpación
de poder por el fiscal general
muchos manifestantes consideran que la
justicia ha muerto
no es solo una guerra entre magistrados
es un golpe de estado
no queremos que la política interfiera y
bloquee la investigación lo que queremos
es verdad y Justicia desde principios de
semana la investigación se ha convertido
en una batalla jurídica el lunes
tardvitar decidió reanudar Las
investigaciones que habían estado
suspendidas durante 13 meses imputando
al fiscal a hassanuidad y a otras siete
personas la fiscalía rechazó
inmediatamente todas las decisiones del
después llegando incluso a liberar el
miércoles a todos los detenidos sin
juicio desde el inicio de la
investigación
después de tanta injusticia por fin
Somos libres Esta es la libertad que
hemos estado esperando durante tres años
se suponía que nos liberarían cada
semana nos decían que íbamos a salir
desde el inicio de las investigaciones
taractar un juez sin afiliación política
conocida se ha puesto a encontrar gran
parte de la élite política el magistrado
implicó también al ex Primer Ministro
hasandiab y antiguos ministros como unos
de los responsables de la tragedia la
explosión del 4 de agosto de 2020 fue
causada por el almacenamiento de varias
toneladas de nitrato de amonio en un
almacén al Menos 215 personas murieron y
partes enteras de beirut quedaron
devastadas